(singing in foreign language)
- I never thought in a million years
that I would be here in Japan singing
the music that my
grandmother introduced me to.
I'm a testament to say that no matter
how big your dreams are, they
can definitely be achieved.
(speaking foreign language)
(singing in foreign language)
Enka is a form of Japanese music,
so it's only sung in Japan.
It is considered a older genre of music.
I call it Japanese blues because
all of the lyrics are
very sad, melodramatic.
They often talk about
lost loves and heartbreak.
It uses a lot of imagination.
It really doesn't spell out the
meaning of the song for you,
so everyone who listens to the music
can have their own interpretation.
(speaking foreign language)
I was born and raised in
Pittsburgh, Pennsylvania.
My grandmother, she was
originally from Yokohama.
I basically went to my grandmother's house
just about every weekend.
She listened to enka music all the time.
I think it was a way for her
to keep Japan in her heart,
even while she was living in the U.S.
I started singing around five years old.
My grandmother would always
say, "You sing so well."
Just to see a smile on her face
would just brighten my day
because I loved her so much.
Because I had so much love for enka
and wanted to know what the
lyrics I was singing meant,
I started studying Japanese in high school
and throughout college.
I was always interested in Japan
and where my mom and my
grandmother came from.
So I moved to Japan to
become an enka singer.
(singing in foreign language)
The very first time I stood on the stage
and sang for a crowd was actually on TV.
Kinda like American Idol.
I was given so much praise and
it made me feel really, really good.
They were just so surprised.
Like, why would would a 20-something American
be listening to a genre like this?
And it kinda worked in my favor.
(singing in foreign language)
I started singing professionally in 2008.
There's never been an
American whose been on stage
singing enka professionally here in Japan.
I've had the opportunity to
do different types of songs.
Children's songs, musicals, TV dramas.
I think I've been really embraced
wholeheartedly from the Japanese audience.
Me singing enka really was a way for me
to connect to Japan and
connect with my grandmother.
And to this day, the love I
have for enka has not changed.
(speaking in foreign language)